yeah welcome to a new game against
smooth smooth smooth smooth okay Queens
gambit is Iceland right here you learn
your flags after a while you learn the
flex okay so Queens gambit let's see
what line okay we get it tirage really
wow I didn't even know that this move
existed
yeah what is the point I take here and
how do you not lose this porn
I mean the a couple of gambits cool
there are a couple of gambits around but
I don't really Queen takes 96-94 yeah
maybe 94 intending 96 with we are
destroying his structure okay so 96
Bishop f2 with some is something to
reckon with so probably go here
well
yeah okay maybe as a way to pawn takes
Queen takes I don't know yeah maybe
politics looks more bit more dynamic
Knight c3 and d5
so 95 job should I be worried about him
taking only three done yeah I don't
think I can do so much against that it
would at least um strengthen my my
Center a bit
jo- move
you
yeah it looks like it said it's
difficult to to keep the the pawn even
that's amazing probably i played this
far to pass a flame okay come on
now therefore i can play Bishop see one
maybe maybe I should shot even I mean
Bishop b2 is not just such a matter of
the porn but you can take the form this
is what I do I have some trick takes 24
yeah well whatever at least them this is
a very nice bishop if you move the night
st5 maybe this isn't so bad in I was
some very skeptical
yeah I can play rook e1 and so on it's
not it's not bad but i was thinking i
would just i'm just a pawn up but this
isn't the case he really had some
activity with f5
now he's got lots of weaknesses on the
e-file and so on it's quite a nice
position Wow yeah okay you cannot cannot
sit and way down I understand so how to
how to activate now
night efore to c5 but this of course
neglect some control over d5 I don't
have a direct way to go about that
problem oh wait I have an idea want some
bad idea I thought maybe Bishop takes
Bishop takes and b3 idea should be to
enter use it on the long diagonal
okay come on play play save him first
let's see what he is coming up with
I really tricky
and now I do that she moves the night
I've got night f6 and g5 is hanging
night c5 your queen d7 was maybe not the
one to go at least that's my first first
impression
and I think I can even play b3 near now
be three Bishop b2 would be would be a
dream
yeah if you move the night away and he
needs to do this to to get something on
the dipole I'll play the five no matter
what and then this would be this
diagonal is just just amazing so way
three kick it kick it away you should
g-form back of play plates plates simple
and we don't don't need to look for the
absolute best way give five back on tape
take it and play d5 next
yeah quindi for Bishop evil yeah Bishop
before some too much yeah this is some
again but that's really not working this
this is not working simply I can I can
take you six and I'm a pawn up but he
put up the good resistance maybe I
should shut even play Queen d4 but it's
not not so clear I mean he's got two
pieces developed and have a bit behind
in development so you know maybe Queen
takes the better move I don't know Queen
takes I thought that maybe this was
possibility if you look at this what
night before or Bishop before this this
could be compensation they are there are
lines like that and another in other
similar openings
hmm yeah I don't know this looks looks
like a not the way to go probably
shrimps five yeah Bishop e3 I thought
about that and when it looks so ugly
it's maybe possible now I'm threatening
really not XD six yeah okay thanks for
watching this